[Musique]
quel pays est le plus important
producteur de légumineuses les
légumineuses sont cultivés dans
pratiquement toutes les régions du globe
mais avec 25 % de la production mondiale
soit quelque 22 millions de tonnes l'ied
est sans contredit le plus gros
producteur mondial
dans ce grand pays du sud de l'asie les
variétés les plus cultivés sont les pois
chiches et les pois perdrix là il est
aussi le plus gros consommateur de
légumineuses avec environ le tiers de la
demande mondiale
les indiens on consommerait pas moins de
26 millions de tonnes par année
le canada lui se situe au second rang
des pays producteurs avec 8 millions de
tonnes produites suivi par le myanmar et
la chine la production mondiale de
légumineuses a connu une croissance
fulgurante au cours des 30 dernières
années et a même doublé
elle dépasserait maintenant les 80
millions de tonnes le haricot en
particulier semblent avoir la cote et
représente à lui seul un tiers de la
production mondiale